what's up reject nation i'm greg outlet
now I'm drawing Humphrey we are gonna
watch from the channel super Luigi Logan
SML movie Jeffy skip school this is a
topper war to your video requests from
patron Lynnae our darlin from Texas I've
never seen super Luigi Logan no idea
we're about to hop into
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we go take a dump
coz I read to take a dump do your
homework
Oh preacher man I know but I can help
Brian maybe no no I'm actually off the
clock right now
Mario yeah he's just this is your
grandpa retirement home because he
grabbed one of the nurses bus
yeah Veronica was pretty upset about it
so I'm just gonna limo oh good idea
come in John okay you're right here
pretend to be me while I go play video
calculators and ragged horses I don't
understand it
alright guys I'm in my closet
you got a pretty squad up I'm gonna play
oh we're gonna do your math homework
okay unprofessional
okay well you always get me so where do
your math homework okay right right no
math homework okay all right so first
question
ping-pong has two balls he is one ball
with paddle how much pain is he in no
the answer would be a lot he's in a lot
of thing oh yeah
so uh question number two some dough
toes done they paint for toes and quits
because of Ingram Tonio how many toes no
paint see no the answer is six and they
stopped so it's a six no paint okay
number three slum-like dong had 14 cats
and four cucumber he ate four of them
four of what did he eat kitty yes
correct
four cats yeah so uh okay number four
she can eat China the Chinese chicken
lays eight eggs it takes twenty eggs to
make egg drop soup
how many eggs have dropped in the soup
drop
[Music]
no no not 20 only eight cuz only the
chicken only lays eggs can't drop 20
only has eight oh yeah I said the last
question is girl in hospital says
something wrong with Verena after she
have for baby what wrong with Verena
[Music]
very loose I just help you with it so
you can go to school tomorrow okay all
right your SpaghettiOs new toys new
SpaghettiOs Tong Lu Serena
imagine you were doctor think so Jimmy
Jimmy just eat you don't take pills
Jimmy just eat your stupid SpaghettiOs
it's not right Oh Jimmy there's
SpaghettiOs you've eaten before
[Music]
okay well you never take that average of
you so you don't need you just playing
around
okay so I'll wake up in the morning to
go to school okay good
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we saw so we we did real straight go
straight
we helped
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no that's an old man he has a it's the
wrong color too but you see anything
above the next video Mario Goetze eye
surgery or some [ __ ]
anything Peter light it on down for you
son
[Laughter]
[Music]
Wow
we need to buy a Jeffy puppet what is
this channel and how soon can I
subscribe well in between cuts I see
here that they've been around for about
nine years those gonna say this feels
like old school YouTube yeah it
definitely feels like someone just
picked up a video camera and just
started improving with their friends I'm
taking his videos come out within the
past year it's pretty cool that they
haven't lost that vibe feels like just
one dude where they can't like look the
camera strapped to the guy or something
yeah cuz you could just hold the puppet
right in front of your torso if you
wanted yeah it seems like the cameras
like strapped him somewhere and he's
just using both hands to control the
puppets but then and now there's some
obvious shots where I'm like oh you
probably need another person for that
one right there's probably
behind-the-scenes photo where there's
that forty people on a set with a boom
and all kinds of things to make these
happen this is an interesting video to
start off with right in the midst of
something that probably already has some
pre-established storyline to some degree
here and some sort of primer for what
the sensibility of humor would have been
yes but it's still pretty cool that in
the age of yellow dollar bill signs and
constant D monetization there's so many
channels talking about it all the time
us included that this channel is still
willing to commit hard core to what it
is people merchants don't care about any
of that
who can clearly just sell the Jeffie
puppets yeah they all has a profit off
of that because this is some pretty hard
are racy content I was gonna say this is
like the kind of stuff that we would
have been
trying to make back in high school or
something this feels like something out
of like a high school video production
yes or it's just as offensive as
possible but also just as gleefully
weird and whimsical as possible some
weird alternate world in the Mario Luigi
universe yeah where Mario has a
grandfather
it's like an American hick version of
the Mario family yeah if Trailer Park
Boys was also Super Mario there would be
this Rob Zombie made Super Mario this is
what it would be right here
yeah just with less blood yeah
definitely the rawness of it I can
definitely appreciate because you like
the hands are all in framing all over
the place
yeah it's like so rough around the edges
that that's part of the charm quite
racist I was a little surprised like wow
all the Asian stereotypes they're
puppets they can get away with it that's
what's happening right here that's how
happy time murderer's got away with all
the things they did yeah yeah yeah
puppets can make fun of any other
puppets what you gotta give respect
sometimes for just how edgy some
contents willing to be because sometimes
it's just like wow they're just saying
that they're they've committed hardcore
to this racist joke especially like
making fun of Chinese and Japanese
people oh god one the whole recurrent
trying to get to the history of Pearl
Harbor yes [ __ ] it was a grandpa being
this like hardcore
alright war hero yeah well and yeah the
grandpa is just sort of spouting off
like every possible geriatric old guy
yeah Metamucil and all that stuff I
thought this could have been like 10
minutes honestly I did appreciate that
the twist becomes like it's an actual
plot point that Mario has some kind of
face blindness word yeah he just can't
recognize anybody if they're wearing the
wrong t-shirt yes yes see above the neck
and like those kind of jokes were
definitely my favorite in this yeah yeah
yeah because it's so dumb yeah that it
comes back around to being funny yeah
it's like if this video is one of those
force of nature sort of viral videos
where I'm sitting here and there's an
expression on my face the entire time
sometimes it's horror sometimes it's
shock sometimes it's laughter sometimes
it's begrudging laughter I kept
wondering like how they made this it
just feels like there's some guy and it
has a
we're just making all this appetizers in
his own house chillin but what school
would allow them to shoot this they
think this isn't an actual school of
some of this stuff unless they have a
better shot for it looks like a room
they have in their own house that they
just made so close the shots are here
and everything yeah you don't get any
wides here but Jeffy the troublemaker
some of this is flat-out offensive and
some of this is like really smart of
satire to a certain degree - it's a
little bit everything I think this is
one of those throwing everything at the
wall and seeing what sticks videos yeah
some of it sticks and some of its must
okay but you gotta give a credit as a
reverent and as vulgar as it is they are
still fully thought-out characters to a
weird degree and they're keeping the
old-school YouTube flavor alive with a
4.3 million like it's nice to know the
new channel could be that big and still
have that old-school YouTube Flair yeah
absolutely
even if it's not your style of comedy
it's somebody's dead alright guys well
make sure to subscribe to super Luigi
Logan if you haven't done so already you
can subscribe to us the real rejects
click our notification really get
notified when we have a video up and
Lynnae I could see why you asked us to
cover this usually it's a wrestling
video that's not able to go up on
YouTube and now you asked for something
entirely different but I think it's
because you work at a school and I
imagine this Jeffery kid is probably a
lot like the students you have to deal
with this probably brings a lot of
sentiment to your heart yeah or it
brings out all the rage within you maybe
this is your outlet of sorts that you
have to deal with maybe that's why
you're so into wrestling is maybe that's
your one way to feel the catharsis of
all that pent-up rage and frustration
from the kids were sitting up all night
playing for tonight so if you were smart
you would use some of those wrestling
moves on those kids when no one else is
looking like a good Stone Cold Stunner
like a good old abuser mmm-hmm
just elbow some kid it's okay if you do
good yeah just don't get it caught on
camera like don't spin on a dog
yeah don't spit on a dog but you can hit
a kid with your elbow again as long as
our cameras partner
not a dog spit on the kid